- The day today is an
ominous March 13th, 2020.
Why do I say ominous?
'Cause it is Friday the
13th, but not to worry.
In this video, we're gonna
remain alert, not anxious.
I'm not gonna give you
any number updates starting this video,
because I think the numbers
are horribly inaccurate,
especially here in the United
States for one main reason.
We don't have enough testing kits
to find out who actually has this virus.
But let's talk about it, you ready?
The WHO has officially
labeled this virus a pandemic.
Not really surprising, two videos ago,
we said that it was
technically a pandemic then,
now we have this label on it.
What does it mean for you?
Practically speaking, not much.
It means that this virus is
internationally spreading,
it can spread through
countries very easily,
there's more funding available,
more communication happening
between health agencies.
But on a day to day standpoint,
this pandemic label
shouldn't really affect you.
You may have noticed
there's closures happening,
cancellations happening
all across the board.
In fact, I had five, six speaking
engagements get postponed.
Speaking at Johns Hopkins,
Yale, The College of New Jersey.
All of these have to take a
back seat for public safety.
Now I know seeing all these cancellations
can get you worried,
but we're gonna stay alert not anxious.
Cancellations are a good thing.
This is a public health measure
that actually shows solidarity
within our community.
Because when we shut down these events,
we limit how this virus spreads.
Why is it important to
limit this virus spread?
Because we have to offer
community protection
to those who can't protect themselves.
This means the elderly,
those with serious medical
chronic conditions,
and those who are immunocompromised,
possibly because of a medical condition
or a medication they may be taking.
Traditionally we offer
this type of herd immunity,
or community protection through vaccines.
Unfortunately we cannot
make a vaccine this quickly
and the WHO has stated the
earliest possible timeline
for this vaccine would happen mid 2021.
So we can't expect a vaccine soon,
but we are gonna be talking
about possible treatments
in the coming minutes.
Another reason I've talked about on CNN
of why it's important to
limit community spread.
Because we do not want a run on hospitals.
In Italy they're experiencing
a tremendous need
for equipment, for doctors
because their hospitals
are getting overrun
with patients who need respiratory
support, who need fluids
and here in the United States,
we simply do not have enough ICU beds
if everyone is to get
this virus simultaneously.
So by slowing the rate at
which this virus infect others,
we're doing something
called flattening the curve.
Traditionally when a population
of individuals gets sick,
there's a bell curve that happens.
What we like to do is flatten this curve.
The way we do that is by
limiting crowded events.
Here in New York State,
we actually have a rule,
no events with greater
than 500 individuals.
We're probably gonna see
that tighten even further
and I would not be surprised
to see schools shutdown.
Because we want to flatten that curve,
we wanna decrease the spread,
so that our hospitals can manage
the individuals who are sick
and not run into a problem
like they have in Italy.
Many of my patients and
friends have been asking
about what they can do
to protect themselves
from this novel coronavirus.
It's still personal responsibility.
You have to not go out when you're sick,
you have to limit your
exposure to large crowds,
while you may have tickets
for a show you wanna see,
or maybe your sporting
event is still going on.
Try and limit that spread.
The CDC put an urgent
warning out to those over 60,
I think that warning should
apply to more people.
And again, it doesn't mean
we should be panicking.
This isn't a panicdemic,
this is a pandemic.
What we should be doing is
staying alert, not anxious
and the way we do that is by
getting quality information
from sources like the WHO and CDC,
so that we can be best
informed to protect our health
and the health of our family members.
In all honesty, I wanted to
film this video yesterday,
but I was working a 12 hour
hospital shift seeing patients.
What did I learn?
There's truly a scarcity of supplies.
N95 masks, which are
the properly fit masks
that we as health
professionals should be wearing
to decrease viral spread.
The surgical masks,
those inexpensive masks
you see on social media.
We need our patients to wear those
so they don't get us sick.
And finally, and the most
importantly, testing kits.
We need more testing kits.
We need to be able to
identify who has COVID-19
and who has another virus
that's less important
in this given time.
Without testing kits, we can't
properly quarantine people,
and we're obviously quarantining people
that do not have COVID-19
and that's truly a problem.
So I call on the White House
Coronavirus Task Force,
get us the equipment we
need on the front lines
as health professionals
because the last thing we want to happen
is to have more doctors,
nurses, CMAs, PAs,
all of us on the front lines to get sick
and then not have anybody to
take care of our patients.
Let's go ahead and jump into the subject
that I'm most passionate
about, misinformation.
- People die from the flu
and this is very unusual.
And it is a little bit different,
but in some ways it's easier
and in some ways it's
a little bit tougher.
- There are some similarities
between the flu and COVID-19
but there are very serious differences.
Similarities, they're both viruses,
they both spread through
respiratory droplets,
the symptoms are similar.
However the severity is quite different,
the lethality is quite different.
And most importantly,
we do not have a vaccine
and we don't have an anti-viral
medication, FDA approved,
to treat COVID-19.
What does all that mean?
It means the lethality
rate is gonna be higher.
More people are gonna lose their lives
because of COVID-19 than the flu.
More people are gonna get infected
with COVID-19 than the flu
because it's more infectious.
Early research suggests
this virus can spread
two to three times faster
than the influenza virus.
This is why it's become a
pandemic in a matter of months.
There is a chain letter going around
titled "Information on Coronavirus".
I can't believe I'm even
saying the term chain letter,
but it is going around
via email and Twitter,
I saw even Brother Nature retweeted it
and it has like 114,000 retweets on it.
It has quote unquote Stanford
notes on Coronavirus.
Stanford came out and
did a public message,
said they have nothing to do with this.
Because this misinformation
is spreading like wildfire.
Some of the things written in here.
Drinking warm water is
effective for all viruses.
If you have a runny nose and
sputum, you have a common cold.
It talks about a 10 second breathing test
that if you're able to hold
your breath for 10 seconds
you don't have the
novel coronavirus, what?
None of this is medically accurate
and this goes to show
that just because a celebrity
gets a lot of retweets
or likes on a given post,
it does not mean it's
accurate information.
Trust the CDC, WHO, or trust
the health professionals
that are actually dealing
with this crisis head on.
Let's talk about two
pieces of misinformation
that I think even some medical experts
have gotten themselves confused over.
One is about using certain supplements
to help prevent or treat
the novel coronavirus,
zinc being a primary example.
Yes, there was a study that showed
zinc interrupts replication of this virus,
which is a good thing.
However, very important, if
you actually read the study,
it shows that the zinc needed
to be inside your actual cells
not just in your bloodstream
or in your stomach,
in the cells.
The way that the research
got the zinc into the cells,
was through a zinc ionophore.
It's basically like a little tunnel
that allowed the zinc to enter the cell
then it interfered with the
viral replication, good stuff.
However, taking a zinc lozenge
does not create a zinc
gateway, a zinc ionophore,
to enter into our cells.
So no, taking zinc by mouth
does not disrupt the viral replication.
This is why we need to be very
careful when we read research
to actually read it, not
just skim over the abstract.
Next, let's move on to
surface contamination.
How long does the novel
coronavirus live on surfaces?
There's been some really good research
coming out in this area,
and the range that we're seeing
is from hours to a day or
two, sometimes three days
if we see perfect temperature, humidity,
and surface conditions.
This virus does live longer
on plastic and steel surfaces,
meaning non-porous ones.
So you want to be sure to be wiping down
commonly used surfaces, like
keyboards, like faucets.
That's obviously very important,
but the doctors that are
going out there and saying
that it lasts one to two weeks.
Practically speaking, especially
outdoors, that's not true.
And in the one study that came out
talking about this 9 day period,
it was for a very specific
sub-strain of this virus,
it does not apply to
the majority of cases.
Also I'm gonna reiterate,
the primary driver of
how this virus spreads
is through respiratory droplets.
Meaning that you inhale them,
you touch your mouth, eyes, or nose.
So surface contamination is
a possible way to spread it,
but the main one is those
aerosolized particles.
It doesn't mean it's airborne,
because it's not technically airborne,
it's aerosolized particles
that are temporarily hanging in the air.
That's what I call germ hang time.
That's why in the winter time,
there's a higher chance you get sick,
'cause the air is drier,
more germs hanging in the air
for a longer period of time,
easier to get sick.
The longest that we've
seen them hanging around,
three hours for this novel coronavirus.
So it is possible to walk into a room
that's empty where
someone's sneezed before
and inhale some of these
respiratory droplets,
but outdoors that's not something
you should be concerned about.
Because the sun, with its UV rays,
is our most powerful disinfectant.
Let's move on and talk about
a common conspiracy question
that I've been getting asked.
Did this virus come out of a lab in China?
If conspiracy theorists believe
that this is a bio terrorism weapon,
it's a really bad one.
'Cause it's crushed the Chinese economy
as well as the international economy.
It has a very low lethality rate
for something that's
considered to be deadly.
If it escaped out of a lab in China,
which we have no evidence for that.
It does not change anything
that we have to do now
to protect ourselves.
You wanna talk about after the fact,
once we're investigating this virus, cool.
But right now, we need
to take actionable steps
to stay alert not anxious,
be educated, and protect
ourselves and our family members.
Let's move on to potential treatments
because that's what I'm
most optimistic about.
There are well over 300 clinical
trials ongoing right now.
And that's a good and bad thing.
Bad because there's some medications
that shouldn't be tested, are.
And it's taking away from the patient pool
that can be enrolled in these studies.
Good because we're getting
a lot of different options
tested all at once.
Leading the way, Remdesivir.
It's an anti-viral medication
that was primarily used to treat Ebola.
The way that it works
is interrupts the viruses
replication cycle.
Let's think back, how does a virus work?
It infects your cell,
then it hijacks the cells
own inside machinery
and replicates itself.
We wanna stop that process
to prevent the virus from spreading.
Hopefully Remdesivir does that.
Other medications that
we have being tested,
HIV medications like Kaletra,
Chloroquine, which is
anti-malarial medication.
All showing some initial promise,
but we gotta get those studies in.
In fact the NIH has a
study going on in the U.S.
with Remdesivir that's
scheduled to have some results
by next month, I'm really
excited to see those.
Because if we can decrease
the complication rate,
like pneumonia, secondary
infections, even death.
We could make a huge impact
for those suffering with COVID-19.
If you suspect that you have COVID-19
or any virus for that matter,
call ahead to your health
professional's practice
before just heading over,
it's really important.
In fact here's what I want you
to take away from this video.
Wash your hands, wash your
hands, wash your hands,
I'm gonna say it again.
Stay home, especially if you're sick.
Three, avoid large
crowds if at all possible
because that's how the virus spreads.
Four, try not to touch
commonly touched surfaces
with your fingertips, use your elbow, hip
whatever you can instead.
Five, don't believe
misinformation from celebrities
just because they get a
lot of likes or retweets.
Only the CDC, WHO, or other
verified health professionals.
And finally, don't panic.
Stay alert, not anxious, so
you can make the best decisions
for yourself and your family members.
I put together a couple playlists for you,
check 'em out right here or right here.
I wanna know what you like better
while you stay happy and healthy.
(soft intense music)